it was on Christmas Eve day December
24th during Columbus's first voyage to
the Americas that one of his ships the
Santa Maria drifted onto a bang due to
the fact that the helmsman thinking the
seas were calm enough gave the control
of the tiller to one of his young
subordinates this had proven to be a
huge mistake as the boy managed to run
the boat across some shallow waters
where it got permanently stuck and
damaged this happened to occur of the
coasts of today's northern Haiti and so
the expedition decided to go ashore and
seek help from the local Arawak people
who were a subgroup of the broader Taino
people which inhabited the Caribbean
they soon came into contact with the
ruler of the mauryan chieftain cotton
Akari he wasn't only chief in Hispaniola
as the island was divided into five
chiefdoms however he was the only one
who mattered to the Europeans at the
moment after talking to guaca Nagari
as Columbus his son recalls the chief
and the people were extraordinarily nice
more than happy to help out giving the
Spaniards large canoes storage houses
and manpower to salvage and store
whatever they could get from their
mobile ship afterwards Gordon agari
along with multiple traders from the
surrounding tribes met with Columbus
himself during the conversation the
traders enthusiastically traded all
their gold for the Spaniards Eagle bells
as they were fascinated with the sound
they made after seeing the amount of
gold that the local people possessed and
the promise of guac and gari to get more
from the Cibao Mountains located in
today's dominican republic columbus
decided that the mobile santa maria and
it's saved cargo be dismantled and used
for construction of the colony where he
will leave the men which are most
important and setting up such college ie
carpenters physicians tailors etc and
total 36 men were left behind this
colony which was named La Navidad was to
wait for Columbus has returned all while
gathering information on the new world
and trading with the local natives
largely for gold before Columbus is
departure guaca Nagari
assured Columbus that if anything were
to happen to his men he will help out
the Christian colony in any way he can
Columbus Thank You Arcana gari and also
ordered his men that if anything
ill-fated were to occur that they'd drop
all their gold into the constructed
wooden fortress as well as to be found
by Columbus
he returns now with the first ever
European colony excluding the Vikings
established in the new world Columbus
set sail back to Europe a year later in
1493 Columbus returned from Spain to the
town of La Navidad where upon entering
the town Harbor found the entire colony
burned down with no gold and no
survivors confused and horrified by the
site Columbus ordered his men to check
for bodies and look into the fortress as
well for the missing gold there was no
gold in the well but several dead bodies
of the colonists were found in a nearby
field this however still did not explain
what happened to the entire colony then
suddenly the brother of Gorka nigari
accompanied by several alternatives
appeared and wish to speak to Columbus
upon hearing his story it all became
clear after Columbus's departure the men
of La Navidad quickly started to mingle
with the local woman living with four or
six women at once most of them also
started to hoard larger and larger
stashes of gold oftentimes bartering for
gold behind each other's backs
soon the competition between getting
more woman and more gold turned into
frequent arguments and it became so bad
that some of the colonists started to
kill each other with all this chaos and
hostility in the colony sound the
Spaniards decided to leave for the
mountains where they heard the golden
mines were located they most likely
entered the neighboring chiefdom of
Magua which angered the local ruler
killing all of the Spaniards that dare
to come for his gold outraged by the
actions of the colonists the ruler
organized a full-on military attack on
monavie de to get rid of the remaining
Europeans when they attacked came la
navidad was defended by only eleven men
with everyone else either dead or
fleeing with all their gold and wives to
other tribes perhaps even on different
islands Howard 11 Spaniards were alone
because guac and gari honored his
promise to Columbus and with his men
joined in the
they were still extremely unnumbered and
after some fearsome fighting the
colleges got overwhelmed by the sheer
number of the attackers when eventually
the fortress was broke into all
remaining Europeans along with some of
guano Gary's men were slaughtered and
the entire colony gets set on fire
what kind of guy he himself managed to
escape but was injured and that is why
his brother came to visit Columbus as
guaca Nagari was unable due to his
injuries
Columbus appalled by his men's actions
later thanked Gorgon gari personally for
honoring his promise after which the two
exchanged gifts and Columbus went on to
try to settle other areas of Hispaniola
and so goes the disastrous story of the
first ever European colony in the New
World
if we're not counting the Vikings this
video was brought to you by no one
because I'm too small to get a sponsor
actually no scratch that this video is
brought to you by coffee logs of coffee
and tea and also actually Photoshop
computers late night but whatever
basically this video wasn't brought to
you by money because I can't even
monetize my videos thanks YouTube
actually again scratch all of what I
said
this video and all the videos I made in
the past eight months were brought to
you by NAR Buress for $1 each what a
heck of a deal
[Music]